[music]
>> Alhamdulillah.
As-salatu was-salam ala Rasulillah wa
ala alihi wa sahbihi ajma'in. Amma ba'd,
a'udhu billahi min ash-shaytani rajim.
Bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim. Fas'alu ahla
dh-dhikri in kuntum la ta'lamun. Rabbi
shrah li sadri wa yassir li amri wahlul
uqdatan min lisani yafqahu qawli. I
welcome all of you once again
with this Islamic lecture. As-salamu
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Wa
alaykum as-salam
wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
May peace, mercy, and blessings of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala be on all of you.
And we continue with the session of
techniques
of dawah related public speaking.
The point number 2A we discussed last
on Thursday. I call it 2A because it
wasn't mentioned here.
Now we go to point number three.
Wear formal clothes.
Avoid t-shirts,
jeans,
and other casual wear.
Normally, when you give an Islamic
lecture,
especially in a public talk, unless
you're
giving a talk
in a camp, which is a youth camp, and
the atmosphere
is casual.
And then if you wear a casual clothes,
no problem. But imagine
if you have gone for formal lecture,
and you're wearing
t-shirt,
which is
half sleeve, and then Bermudas, and
stone washed jeans,
it doesn't give a very good appearance.
So, when you're giving an Islamic talk,
always be formal,
unless
it is specifically meant where they're
going or giving a talk in a youth camp,
or where they've gone for picnic. In
this situation,
if you wear formal, no problem.
But if you wear casual in this
particular situation,
it can be an exception. Generally, it's
preferable
on a normal circumstances,
you should wear formal clothes.
The formal clothes differ
from country to country.
Normally, but not in Western country,
it's a suit and a trouser.
Or
it can be
a trouser and a shirt, but a formal
shirt.
Not a t-shirt with something mentioned.
Normally, I find that
sometimes something you mention which is
not even Islamically correct
on the t-shirt,
and it goes against the purpose of your
talk.
It's normally a suit.
When you're wearing a suit and wearing a
tie,
see to it that the knot is correct.
See to it that the knot is on the top,
not half down.
Normally, when you go to office and you
feel a bit hot, you take out a tie. And
I find many people come and give a talk
where the knot is down,
and they're giving a talk.
That looks
It's not un-Islamic. It's not haram.
But it gives a very casual appearance
and
it seems that the person doesn't know
how to wear a tie.
Now, there are certain rules and
regulations and
certain
ethics of wearing suit, which some may
be aware, some may not be aware.
Many a time when I go, people ask me
that the lower button is open. Please
close it.
They don't realize that normally
it is
the style that when you wear a suit and
if it's a three-button suit
when you're standing, you normally leave
the lower button open.
It's unsaid rule.
If you close it, no one can stop you.
But those who know what is wearing a
suit
if you button the third button, they'll
know this person doesn't know what's the
the rules and regulation of wearing a
suit. Either you keep all the three
buttons open
or you can keep the top button and the
second button on the way I'm doing. Or
you can even keep only the middle button
on.
This also is there, but I personally
prefer buttoned up. If you like, it's
not a problem.
But this is a little bit
little bit casual, but not very casual.
Normally, you you do like that when
you're doing some work and you want to
feel more comfortable. But I personally
prefer that it should be buttoned up and
see to it that only the
first and the middle button is closed.
If it's a two-button suit, then only the
second button should be open.
But when you stand
the ruling is that the lower button
should be open. It may differ with a
person who's a stylist. But this is the
general rule that the lower button
should be open.
And many a times I find that people are
wearing suit for the first time and you
find that the shoulders are broad
and the sleeves are
covering half the palm.
Some people
they buy a suit and if it's mentioned
that sherwani, so they keep the sherwani
brand. They're supposed to cut it. And
they think
that it should be there.
It is there when it's hanging, it's kept
in the showroom. When you get it, you
have to cut it.
It's like if you wear a watch normally,
if you buy expensive watches, the dial
has a covering to protect it. Once you
start wearing it, you have to remove it.
It's a small point which I have noticed
it very common. And then we realize that
this person is wearing the suit for the
first time, or he's not used to wearing
or he's not in that
particular league of people who are used
to wearing
suit.
And the way you tie the knot, all these
are minor points. We won't go into the
detail.
But one thing should be noted that
if you're wearing a shirt,
that shirt should not have very small
checks.
Does anyone know the reason why the
shirt should not have very small checks?
Okay, fine. I've not discussed this
anytime
before in many of my training programs.
Because if they're shooting, so it may
jitter it may give a jittery feeling on
the camera. And I tell him that don't
wear a tie which is with checks, small
checks.
The reason is there is something called
as moire.
Moire is a phenomena
where there is jittering
when
you take a photograph or you do any
artwork, so electronically there's a
jitter.
So this is only when you're giving a
talk and it's being video recorded.
If it is a talk which is not being video
recorded, there's no problem.
There's nothing specific that Zakir Naik
doesn't like checks.
I don't mind checks.
So if you're wearing small checks or
very close lines, even if you wear a tie
which has got very close lines or
stripes,
either it's vertical or horizontal,
whichever it is,
there are high chances of moire coming.
And that is the case also with LED.
We'll discuss that on the day when we
have Dawah through satellite.
Now, this is a bit finer point not
mentioned there.
But, I'm trying to give some more
information
in the experience that is
there.
This
I doubt anytime you will hear any Dawah
training program that you should not
wear
checks which are very fine too because
this is a technical issue.
It has nothing to do with Islam, nothing
to do with presentation skills.
And I have not heard in any presentation
skills anyone telling you not to even in
Toastmasters.
And I'm sorry to say I disagree with
many things of the Toastmasters also.
So, this is only if your talk is being
video recorded, you may see a jitter and
you may see waves.
Because the shooting is in lines because
of this checks and the lines,
they can be a jitter.
Point number four,
wear formal
shoes.
Avoid track shoes, slippers, etc. If
footwear are not allowed, wear only
clean and tone socks.
When you wear shoes, it should be formal
shoes. You know, you may get a latest
Nike
shoes very expensive, but imagine it's
an ankler and you're
unless you're going to a youth camp
where they have gone for a camp
or for a picnic, it's okay. Otherwise,
it doesn't give that
prefer to be formal.
Some people go out of the way to give
that casual look with
Normally, I don't prefer that.
So, wear formal shoes.
Imagine if you're wearing completely
blue color shoes with that Nike emblem
and those things shining,
it's not haram.
Many people do it, but there's a formal
dress code.
And when I ask
that when you go
to a particular
invitation or gathering in a five-star
hotel, you won't find a person coming in
Bermuda. They won't allow you also.
There are high-end gatherings where they
say
black tie.
Black tie means what? Who knows black
tie?
Black tie.
Okay, actually, what's the black tie?
It's the tuxedo or you can say the bow
tie that they talk about.
It's not this black tie.
Some of our Muslims will go with black
tie.
Black tie is actually the black bow.
It's a black suit. The dress code is
mentioned there many a time mentioned
dress code
formal. Dress code black tie. Black tie
means black suit
and black bow.
Fine, when I was asked, I was going to
talk in one of these
the 100 most powerful Muslims in UK. And
the dress code was black tie.
I said, "If you want me, I'll come in my
normal
or then I won't give a talk." They
agreed alhamdulillah. Sometimes I
I like being myself.
Not that wearing a black bow is wrong,
but I have an identity.
So, I wore my own thing,
my own dress, and I went there and I
gave a talk. I was supposed to be one of
the main speakers there. So, it's a
formal.
So, similarly, I believe that when
you're giving lectures
in audiences in public, unless to
youngsters in a particular occasion,
better be formally dressed. It gives a
better impression. If you're talking
something which is very hilarious or
joking, that time you wear these
clothes, there's no problem. Islam is
something
which is serious, but you can joke in
between.
That is Islamic jokes, we'll come to
that later on. La
ilaha illallah.
La
La ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun
Rasulullah.
Muhammadun [music]
Arjoo reza kaya Allah.
Habni ataka ya
Antal Kareem.
Minkal atao ya
Antal Azeem ya
Fika rajao ya
Antal Haleem.
Ar-Rahman, As-Sattar, Malikul Mulk,
Al-Ghaffar, Al-Wahhab, Al-Mannan,
Al-Muta'al.
Allahu Allahu ya Rabbi ya
Allahu ya Rabbi ya